le gouverneur républicain de l'état de
la floride promet que ce n'est pas
terminé que chez bichonne
enfants toutes les villes devraient se
partager ce fardeau il ne devrait pas
tomber uniquement sur le dos des états
républicains une cinquantaine de
migrants vénézuéliens ont été envoyés
sur l'île cossue de martha's vineyard
bastion démocrate prisé par l'élite
politique américaine le gouverneur
decency ça lui même affrété les vols à
partir du texte
trajet était tellement long il nous a
fallu un mois pour traverser le mexique
en fait nous sommes rendus explique ce
vénézuélien d'origine après avoir été
accueillis par des travailleurs
communautaires les autorités ont annoncé
que des migrants sont finalement
transféré sur une base militaire depuis
des mois des ténors républicains comme
le gouverneur du texas font transporter
des migrants dans des états démocrates
pour dénoncer les politiques migratoires
de joe biden la tension monte d'un cran
dans les derniers jours quand d'autres
réfugiés ont été envoyées tout près de
la résidence de la vice-présidente
kamala harris
je pense que c'est vraiment le bordel
c'est vraiment horrible la façon dont
ils utilisent des gens comme des pions
il y avait plus de journalistes à mantas
baigneurs qu'il n'y en a jamais eu au
sud de la frontière
vous deviez vous y rendre afin de
constater ce qui se passe la
maison-blanche dénonce ce qu'elle
qualifie de mise en scène alors que les
républicains espèrent que la question
soit un des thèmes centraux lors de
l'élection de mi-mandat ici mélissa
françois radio canada montréal